the Joe Rogan experience in the fellow
Mike nothing when you said and I've seen
you say this on interviews we have 22
years of research showing the single
high fat meal in pairs and öthey lleol
function hmm that study was called it
was from 1997 so no multiple studies and
I can put them up if you want
so that's 22 years of study from the
effect of a single high fat meal on
endothelial function and healthy
subjects so this compared a 900 calorie
diet both were on 900 calories one group
pat was eating 50 grams of fat in one
group with zero grams of fat the high
fat meal was an egg mcmuffin a sausage
McMuffin I'm not talking about the two
hash browns and non caffeinated drink
off from McDonald's yeah I'm not one
well what at which one are you talking
about a bunch okay well I got a bunch to
actually contradict that so that's the
same study the same researcher that did
that study found that taking vitamin C
after the high fat meal completely
eliminated the the effect that it had on
endothelial function which suggests that
a healthy omnivorous diet with plants
wouldn't have the same impact
there was a 2019 review and this is will
be like crecer CEO slash game-changers
adding nuts avocados olives berries
spice blends orange juice red wine and
protein including milk protein to a high
fat meal prevents endothelial
dysfunction and oxidative stress we've
got several studies that suggest that
dairy and egg proteins improve
endothelial function 2015 controlled
trial with 52 subjects dietary proteins
including milk and egg improved
endothelial function 2006 study adding
dietary protein to a high fat meal
prevented postprandial endothelial
dysfunction we have 2009 study followed
subjects for 12 weeks a low-carb diet
improved endothelial function whereas a
low-fat diet decreased it 2007 study
with follows your all of these studies
show that animal proteins don't you know
and endothelial so you have to know more
about nutrition and it's really okay
so first of all you just you compare low
carbon high carb I am NOT a I'm not for
health I'm not promoting high carb all
that wasn't the point the point is that
low carb diets that contain animal
products and that milk and egg protein
have been shown to sort of endothelial
function not worsen it right so we can
pay him in the film was the animal
protein worsens endothelial I because
that is the scientific consensus and we
keep going back to those tell us why
tell us what that is seafood consumption
protects against endothelial damage
seafood is an animal protein
Mediterranean diet which includes animal
products improves pulse wave velocity
blood flow markers of atherosclerosis
these are studies in the peer-reviewed
literature yeah but so what's wrong with
this so the industry funding studies
what you do wait who said anything about
these being industry funding yeah but
what you do is compare everything is
healthy compared to what healthy or
unhealthy compared to what so if you
have a low carb diet and you replaced a
bunch of white sugar and flour you might
not see you know the outcome is going to
be a deep religious a claim that was
made in the film is that animal product
animal proteins worsen endothelial
function like it's listed a whole bunch
of studies especially those suggesting
here's one that says influence of food
patterns on endothelial biomarkers a
systematic review the conclusion was
that healthy food patterns abundant in
fruits and vegetables had a a beneficial
impact on endothelial function
westernized patterns higher intakes of
processed meats sweets fried foods
refined grains were positively
associated inflammation which makes my
point in another no it makes my point
which is quality matters is no more
sausage McMuffin and Egg McMuffins and
you show that I'm not showing that my
studies are ok but let's let him explain
his studies so for example slide 71 I I
purposely didn't include those study
because I don't think that they're a
good thing to compare to
so slide 71 ok there's oh this is nice
because there's a graph right so you can
see
so everyone's saying like that fat in
the blood that's normal or what do you
mean by normal yeah lots of people do
that that's normal that doesn't mean
it's optimal when you see the fat in the
blood and by the way it was a film we
couldn't throw everything in so when you
see fat that's called postprandial like
penis that means after a meal fat in the
blood right that is associated with up
to a 50% decrease endothelial function
which means Nestor nitric oxide is
produced which means that the arteries
can't open up as much less oxygen less
nutrients to the muscles okay so that is
a surgery as you can see in this graph
I don't know so the solid line is the
the tribe no the solder line is how much
your arteries are dieting flow mediated
face so dilation right
so as the triglycerides this is after
the meal okay which was by the way a
shake of whipping cream and liquid
chocolate and nonfat dry milk okay as
the as you eat the meal you can see that
the triglycerides your that's the fat in
your blood see between 2 and 4 hours it
kind of Peaks we measured those athletes
at 2 hours and again this is not just a
film it's been done for over 20 years in
the scientific literature so as you can
see in the graph right Joe as the dotted
line goes up that's the appearance of
more fat in the blood right you get that
liked essence the milkiness of the blood
you can see that very clearly that the
flow media dilation drops so it drops by
11% okay if you look for example some
extent so that when you have those fat
in the blood your ability to your
arteries to expand goes down there's no
like what that's not an egg mcmuffin
that is a milk and whipping cream and
that's it
so now if you go to slide 73 now I agree
this had some so they compared now
they're here yeah we can skip the next
one that was 11% okay so here what I've
done is the only thing I change about
this graph is I put the green dots for
the plant-based meal and the red dots
for the allenburys meal so they were
eating Korean barbeque egg milk oil
mayonnaise rice and vegetables and on
the other hand they were having a vegan
meal of soup kimchi vegetables orange
juice apple so it was match four
calories at 800 calories the green is in
red and the so the green is plants and
the red is animal-based so I don't know
if you want to go into they're basically
you've slide 74
again please try to remember a lot of
people listening also I don't to read
the know you mean you can if you want
here changes of serum triglycerides were
negatively correlated with changes of
FMD for me to flow mediated dilation
well low carb diets often will lower
serum triglycerides and they can finally
not post not post panda li not after the
meal for that which is important to test
because that last for six three hours
and what do you do again you eat another
animal-based meal so the next part draw
this out good then how is it that
triglycerides go down over time if your
body's because your body adapts to it so
Joe can you read a second this study
suggests that acute HTG
hypertriglyceridemia so it's the fat in
the blood which causes endothelial
dysfunction via enhanced oxidant stress
and that and this may pave the way for
the development of our our therosis
Underoath sclerosis under cronic so what
that's saying like in the short using
short term and chronics like long term
is under cute thing it affects your
endothelial function your ability to
exercise and perform and in the long
term effects chronic collisions like
heart disease and if you go to slide 75
remember that chart that we looked at
with the green dots and the red dots 8.2
percent decrease in FMD two hours
following the animal-based meal two
point seven percent increase in FMD two
hours following the plant-based meal
okay so you got less blood flow so Chris
makes out there's no science no evidence
it was just this crazy thing that they
made up it was the co-chair of the
cardiovascular committee for the NFL
that has been researching this for years
I didn't say that James I said there was
a lot of other evidence contradicting it
so right but you're just we want to
bring up study you can put effects of
dietary carbohydrate restriction versus
low-fat diet on flow mediated dilation
this is what you've been talking about
peak flow mediated dilation at three
hours increased from five point one
percent to six point five percent the
carbohydrate restricted group and
decreased from seven point nine percent
to five point two percent in the low-fat
diet right 12-week local
barbra hydrate diet and proves
postprandial vascular function more than
a low-fat diet right because the low-fat
diet has a bunch of like white flour and
stuff in it that's the thing but that's
why there's off off in the low carb
diets due to that the diets with animal
if we're talking about protein the claim
in the film was that animal protein
causes endothelial dysfunction somehow
we've gotten off talking about fat and
I've just I'm not gonna mention many
studies that show that that dietary
proteins including milk and a and
improve endothelial function no they
don't hear nobody shows up what are
these you can't just say a study right
because I'm Chris can bring up dietary
proteins improve endothelial function
under fasting conditions but not in the
post prandial state with no effects on
markers of low-grade inflammation Tricia
in 2015 study okay but dietary proteins
doesn't even necessarily mean
animal-based programs right no it's
including milk and egg including yeah
Chuck this the bottom line is that he
can present any study I'd have to dig
into it see the funding whatever because
it's always what's compared to so you
can show a huge benefit for eggs if you
compare it to Lourdes right you can
there's also these worth proteins that
included soy soy milk and egg and they
all improved endothelial function yeah
and then another dietary protein milk or
soy - a high-fat meal prevented
postprandial endothelial dysfunction and
then there are the two low-carb studies
that I mentioned there's controlled
trial that found that a low-carb
high-fat diet improved pulse wave
velocity which is another marker of
endothelial function there are studies
of the Mediterranean diet which is a
healthy diet pattern that includes some
animal products include improved pulse
wave velocity seafood consumption
protects against endothelial damage
yes come ahead compared to beef it does
can I just say like for example you said
you were trying to refute the study
about the increased risk of cancer colon
cancer between
vegetarians and
right the three times increased risk
with those who had white meat fish or
chicken once or twice a week and then
you go to a meta-analysis which is not
comparing you're comparing fish to bacon
or beef of course comparing anything
that these are controlled trials that
look at dietary proteins milk is an egg
but Chris first of all you have emitted
that you don't even know how to read it
the science is that fair
do you honestly feel qualified to read
even a single paper yes but you don't
know how to read a forestation research
I took a master's level research
methodology class so I'm referring to
studies that are it's a review
literature it's like and you haven't
answered the question like if if if
protein impairs endothelial function why
are studies showing that milk and egg
don't do that
[Applause]